and the Oscar goes to
working Phoenix Joker
[Applause]
[Music]
ever rehearse the character we never
talked really specifically about what he
would do all we really talked about was
script and story and character is it
just me
or is it getting crazier out there
I think his process is one of surprise
for himself
it seemed like it was the only way to do
it because you have the character that's
so erratic and he's not really certain
of what he's gonna do
[Music]
one of the first things I'd said to him
when we started talking about the
character I said you know Arthur has
this grace in him that we don't see it
first he has music in him and it's funny
when you talk to actors it was something
I said with 42 other things but it
really stuck with him and that's what
informed a lot of the dancing in the
script there was really just two moments
of dancing in the movie there's like
five or six
[Music]
yeah
part of finding those moments I have to
say that I worked with this
choreographer named Michael Arnold for a
couple sequences and he'd introduced me
to a lot of idea about movement and
dance in particular one clip that he
showed me it's a song called the old
soft shoe and for some reason it
encapsulated for for me like Joker
trying to kind of come out trying to
emerge
it's hard to explain what an actor
brings to a role but if you like read
two pages of the script and watch those
two pages I've seen it's jaw-dropping
how additive he is to every single thing
when he was 17 my brother wrote this
lyric he said run to the rescue with
love and peace will follow thank you
[Applause]